since lost ended former cast members
have taken their careers in a variety of
different directions but where is Emilie
de Ravin well here's what happened to
the actress who played Claire on lost
just before the final season have lost
wrapped up de Ravin starred in her
biggest film role to date as Robert
Pattinson 'he's love and tristan
remember me de Ravin told the
independent that while there were no
off-screen sparks between them their
on-screen chemistry was the result of a
lot of hard work we spent a lot of time
together talking about our characters in
their relationship because it's so
important to be comfortable together
then when we were actually shooting
everything fell into place and felt
natural it didn't ever feel like we were
reading a scene or going through the
motions
however de Ravin also said it was
difficult to establish that rapport due
to the legions of Twilight fans that
plagued the shoot it was difficult for
Rob and I to figure out the logistics of
a rehearsal when you've got thousands of
people watching even if you're not
looking at them you're aware of it it
can be hard to focus unfortunately after
remember me de Ravin appeared in a
string of movies that just never seemed
to appeal to critics or audiences the
chameleon got terrible reviews operation
endgame only got a limited release in
the United States and love and other
troubles was filmed mostly in Finnish
deer avens most recent role in a feature
film was in the indie movie the
submarine kid though her performance was
considered a bright spot it too fell
flat with critics still de Ravin told
film monthly she's happy doing smaller
films instead of chasing big-time
Hollywood stardom
I love the indie circuit I think there's
some amazing sort of younger or
undiscovered talent out there as far as
directors and just really edgy scripts
they're maybe not going to be as widely
released but just really really
interesting subject matter which
definitely interests me loss was a
cultural phenomenon so when the show
ended many assumed the stars would go on
to even bigger things yet instead many
of them initially struggled Matthew
Fox's attempts to become a movie star
fizzled for instance while Josh Holloway
had
for old projects failed it got to the
point where some pundits joked that
there was a lost curse and de Ravin
wasn't immune her next project Americana
was passed over during pilot season part
of the issue
maybe that der Evan was typecast prior
to playing the pregnant Claire on lost
she also played a pregnant girl in the
film brick and went on to play another
pregnant character in the series Roswell
she told GQ I must have some sort of
maternal draw to me I do love children
but I don't really talk about that in
auditions hi I really love kids but me
but I keep reading scripts that are like
that too it's only fitting that de Ravin
eventually turned to fairytales to break
the curse in 2012 de Ravin join the cast
of Once Upon a Time which was created by
lost writers Edward kitsis and Adam
Horovitz she played Belle for seven
seasons on the hit show which is even
longer than she played Claire unlost
it's actually quite fabulous how as I'm
sure you know they sort of twist around
these fairy tale character she told The
Hollywood Reporter it was just a really
awesome journey to be able to give my
own spin on such a special icon ik
character and to work with such amazing
people de Ravin originally hails from
Australia I'm the only Australian who
loves peanut butter which led to a lot
of homesickness early in her career she
told the independent I don't get home as
much as I would like to I miss my family
so much
my ideal holiday is just to hang out
with them now though she has her own
family in America after divorcing her
first husband actor Josh Jana vets and
2014 de Ravin fell in love with the
submarine kid writer and director Erik
village they got engaged in 2016 the
same year Durov and gave birth to their
daughter Vera and in 2018 de Ravin
celebrated two new milestones she gave
birth to their son Theodore and she
officially became a US citizen you know
what they say home is where the heart is
in 2017 dear Evan told Entertainment
Weekly that she was finally taking some
time off work to focus on her new family
there are things in the works right now
but I've taken the last few
Soph to be a mom because I've been
working since I had a daughter a year
and a half ago so I was just very
excited to be able to do that since then
she's been true to her word with her
only recent project being the 2019 TV
movie a lover scorned it looks like this
phase of her career will be all about
finding a balance between work and
family but with two successful shows and
a few solid films under her belt de
Ravin still has a bright future in
Hollywood if and when she wants it check
out one of her newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about your
favorite stars are coming soon subscribe
to our YouTube channel and hit the bell
so you don't miss a single one
[Music]